do you afterwards when you realize what
what you were finding out you're finding
so how did you react when you and your
colleague the initial reaction well
first the first reaction was we have
made some big mistake in our calculation
because this looks like it's important
and that hadn't been we hadn't said when
we started out we were going to see
what's happening to the hose own layer
we had said what's what's going to
happen to the chlorofluorocarbons and
then when we found out what was
happening to them and followed a little
bit further we realized it would have a
major effect on stratospheric ozone
layer and therefore was a very it was a
major environment global environmental
problem so it that was the realization
that this had suddenly turned from being
an interesting scientific exercise into
a global problem but was very
eye-opening and worrying